Se você cortou gordura para baixar os
triglicerídios do sangue, talvez tenha
feito exatamente o oposto. Um estudo
publicado no American Journal of
Clinical Nutrition em 2024 mostrou que
homens com sobrepeso que passaram apenas
4 dias numa dieta baixa em carboidratos
e alta em gordura, reduziram a gordura
hepática em 35%.
Não foi erro. 35% em 4 dias. Enquanto
isso, a dieta convencional, rica em
carboidratos e pobre em gordura, não
moveu a agulha. E aqui está o paradoxo
que a maioria dos médicos ainda não
entendeu. Comer mais gordura pode
significar menos gordura no seu fígado e
menos triglicéries no seu sangue. Parece
contrainttuitivo, não é mesmo? Deixa te
explicar a bioquímica por trás disso,
porque quando você entende o mecanismo,
as recomendações começam a fazer
sentido.
O fígado tem uma via metabólica chamada
lipogênese, de novo, em português,
claro, fabricação de gordura nova. E de
onde vem a matéria-pra essa gordura
nova? Dos carboidratos. Quando você come
carboidrato sem excesso, especialmente
açúcares e farinhas refinadas, o fígado
converte esse excesso em ácidos grchos
que são empacotados como triglicerides
ou triglicérides e mandados pro sangue
ou armazenados no próprio fígado. Essa é
a receita perfeita para esteatose
hepática ou gordura no fígado. E aqui
entra o primeiro erro do LFET, trocar
gordura por carboidrato refinado. Quando
a indústria alimentícia tirou a gordura
dos produtos, precisou colocar algo no
lugar para manter o sabor. E esse algo
foi o quê? Foi o açúcar. E o açúcar,
especialmente a frutose, é um dos
combustíveis mais potentes para
lipogênese de novo. Um estudo do Journal
of Clinical Investigation com
adolescentes com fígado gorduroso
mostrou que 8 semanas de restrição de
açúcar reduziu a lipogênese de novo de
34,6%
para 24,1%.
Enquanto no grupo controle ela ficou
praticamente igual. A gordura hepática,
ou seja, a gordura do fígado, caiu de
25,5%
para 17,9%,
só tirando o açúcar. O segundo erro é
ignorar a frutose. E aqui a bioquímica é
cruel. Quando a glicose entra no fígado,
ela passa por pontos de controle
metabólico. O fígado consegue dizer: "Já
tenho energia suficiente, não preciso
converter mais". Mas a frutose ela entra
por uma porta lateral, faz o bypass, ou
seja, ela ultrapassa esses controles.
Então o fígado não consegue frear. Toda
a frutose que chega vai ser processada e
uma parte significativa vira
triglicérides.
É por isso que o refrigerante zero é
melhor que o comum, mesmo tendo
adoçante.
Porque o xarope de milho rico em frutose
do refrigerante comum é uma bomba de
triglicerides. O terceiro erro é focar
no colesterol dietético em vez do
açúcar. Durante décadas, ovos e camarão
foram vilões porque coninham ou contêm
colesterol. Mas o que a ciência mostrou
é que o colesterol que você come tem
impacto muito menor no colesterol do
sangue do que o açúcar que você come. O
açúcar aumenta triglicerídeos, diminui o
HDL e aumenta as partículas pequenas e
densas de LDL, que são as realmente
perigosas. Uma metaanálise 2020
publicada na revista Nutrients analisou
38 estudos com quase 6500 adultos e
encontrou que dietas baixas em
carboidratos foram superiores às dietas
baixas em gorduras para reduzir
triglicerídios e aumentar o HDL. O
quarto erro é reduzir gorduras
saturadas, mas aumentar o açúcar. Isso é
exatamente o que aconteceu nas últimas
décadas. A população seguiu as
recomendações oficiais, cortou carne
vermelha, manteiga, gema de ovo, o que
aconteceu? Obesidade explodiu, diabetes
explodiu, fígado gorduroso nem se fala.
Eu não tô dizendo que gordura saturada
em excesso é boa. Eu tô dizendo que
trocar por açúcar foi um desastre de
saúde pública. O quinto erro é não
considerar o índice glicêmico. Nem todo
o carboidrato é igual. Arroz branco, pão
francês e batata frita disparam insulina
muito mais do que batata doce, aveia ou
leguminosa, os feijões. E a insulina é o
maestro da lipogênese de novo. Quando
você mantém a insulina cronicamente
elevada, você está basicamente mandando
um telegrama pro fígado dizendo:
"Fabrica aí mais gordura. Fabrica aí
mais gordura". Um ensaio clínico
randomizado publicado no Enos of
Internal Medicine em 2023 comparou uma
dieta com menos de 20% de energia vinda
de carboidratos contra uma dieta com 50
a 60% de carboidratos em 165 pessoas com
diabetes tipo 2. O grupo Lowcarb teve
melhora significativamente maior na
hemoglobina agricada e perdeu mais peso
mesmo sem restrição calórica. O sexto
erro é eliminar gorduras saudáveis.
ômega-3, azeite de oliva, abacate,
castanhas. Essas gorduras não só não
engordam o fígado, como podem
protegê-lo. O ômega-3, por exemplo, ele
reduz a expressão de genes lipogênicos
do fígado. Ele fala diretamente com o
DNA das suas células hepáticas, dizendo:
"Diminui aí a produção de gordura".
Quando você corta toda a gordura achando
que é tudo igual, você perde essas
ferramentas de proteção. E o sétimo
erro, talvez o mais fundamental, é
acreditar que calorias de gordura são
iguais às calorias de carboidrato. Do
ponto de vista termodinâmico, uma
caloria é uma caloria, não muda nada.
Mas do ponto de vista metabólico,
bioquímico, o destino dessas calorias é
completamente diferente. O estudo de
2024, que eu mencionei no início,
mostrou que em apenas 4 dias de dieta
baixa em carboidratos, os marcadores de
lipogênes de novo despencaram, a
oxidação de gordura aumentou, os corpos
cetônicos subiram e a sensibilidade
hepática insulina melhorou. Tudo isso
sem mudar as calorias totais. O que
mudou foi a composição, menos
carboidrato e mais gordura. Então agora,
antes de você sair comendo bacon em
todas as refeições, um alerta
importante. O mesmo estudo Anas of
Internal Medicine mostrou que a dieta
low carb aumentou o LDL colesterol em
cerca de 14 mg/ dcl comparado à dieta
low fat. Então, não é carta branca paraa
gordura saturada à vontade. A estratégia
inteligente é reduzir carboidratos
refinados e açúcar, manter proteína
adequada e priorizar gorduras de boa
qualidade. Peixes gordurosos, azeite,
abacate, oleaginosas. Não é sobre
eliminar grupos alimentares, é sobre
entender que o modelo mental de que
gordura alimentar vira gordura no corpo
tá completamente errado. O que vira
gordura no fígado de forma muito mais
eficiente é o excesso de carboidrato. Se
você tem triglicentado no sangue, antes
de cortar o azeite da salada, olhe
quanto açúcar, quanto pão branco, quanto
suco de frutas, quanto refrigerante você
está comendo, ok? Esses são os
verdadeiros vilões metabólicos. E se
você está com esteatose hepática,
gordura no fígado e seu médico só mandou
cortar gordura, leve essas informações
para ele. Mostra os estudos, porque a
ciência já mudou. Só falta a prática
médica, a prática clínica acompanhar.
Agora saia do vídeo se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens e
omitir protocolos controversos. Sobre
triglicérides e fígado gorduroso, por
exemplo, eu não posso falar abertamente
sobre as estratégias de jejum
intermitente combinado com restrição de
carboidratos que eu uso em casos severos
ou supementos específicos que aceleram a
reversão da esteatose. Na comunidade
fechada eu não tenho filtro, eu
compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica, incluindo o
protocolo completo de reversão de
esteatose hepática com alimentação, time
de refeições, suplementação com
beberina, cerimarina e ômega-3 nas doses
que realmente funcionam, casos de
reversão que parecem possíveis,
combinações flip que funcionam,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames. Então é basicamente
ter acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários. Nós temos lives semanais
respondendo perguntas, PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para massas,
clique e seja membro. E não é pro
curioso, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quiser ir ainda mais
fundo, tem o nível dois. A cada duas
semanas nós fazemos lives de imersão
total com 2 horas de duração, desse
secando artigos científicos linha por
linha, como os estudos sobre lipogênes
de novo e o metabolismo hepático que a
maioria dos médicos ainda não conhece.
Debatemos controvérsias que ninguém ousa
tocar e revelamos bastidores das
pesquisas que a indústria não quer que
você entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna parte
visível da sua comunidade elite que está
reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo o seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Não é
só sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer ao
ciclo interno de quem está mudando o
jogo. Poucos têm essa coragem. Você tem?
E já que estamos falando aqui de
metabolismo hepático e resistência à
insulina, você precisa entender como a
berberina pode ser tão eficaz quanto a
metiformina para controle glicêmico.
Assiste esse vídeo aqui sobre beberina
versus metiformina, que vai complementar
perfeitamente o que você aprendeu hoje.
Agradecimentos especiais aos nossos
queridos membros dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube.
Estrigo, Juliana Pontes e Ana Medicina,
Antônio Renato, Karim, Lourdet, Carlos
Roveri, Odonor Pinheiro, Cíntia de Assis
Oliveira, Adriane BMS, Jorge Cabral,
Marcelo Pimentel, Cláudia Leitão, Alex
Caldas, Ana Paula Vascular, José
Fortunato Mutinho, FS Machado RJ, Soujo
Cioli, Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril,
Estela Mar Silva Elô Terapias
Integrativas e Saúde Lã.